ON
SUNDAY, RETI HOT FREE AGENT,
NO QUESTION.
STURGEON.
A SCORELESS
FIRST.
BARRY: THIS WAS A GREAT SHOT.
N,
BACK FOR MAYHEW AND YOU SHOT SWD
UP BY THE GLOVE OF JONATHAN
QUICK.
HAD T
STEVE: HE MOVED BY SIMONE, TOO.
AND THE PAD SAVE BY JONA PUCK.
IAFALLO'S IN.
SAVE BY GIBSON.
SOMETHING LIKE
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN THE NET
IS GOING TO GET
THERE FIRST, KEMPESOMEONE HAS GT
THERE.
1-0, LOS ANGELES.
BARRY:.
BEATS THE MAN MORE POPULAR KINGS
PLAYERS, GOT IT ACROSS, OPEN
MIND, THAT SHOT.
GLOVE ASGIBSON, THE TOP OF THE .
QUICK,  CENTERING.
GREAT SAVE BY
THE LEGS, WOW.
AND STOPPED.
AND A REBOUND.
HOW JUST LIKE THAT THE DUCKSKED.
LOOSE PUCK
THREE OR FOUR TIMES.
THE POWER PLAY IS MO FEEL LIKEO.
AND QUY COMES DOWN, STAYS DOWN
UNBELIEVABLE CHANCE FOR BENOIT.!
COMES FROM
THE POINT.
AMAZING SAVED IN THE
BACK OF THE NET YEAH.
STEVE:OVERTURNED!
AND IT'S A GOOD GOAL.
FRONT OF THE NET.
L.A. KINGS.
HE IS STOPPING EVERYTHING.QUICK.
GREAT SAVE BY QUICK